hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute rocket league ich kann das spiel
nicht gut danke ich ja was ganz neues
wir suchen einfach mal nach einem einzel
duell da seht ihr schon eine tolle karre
ich habe einen piratenhut aber das spiel
nicht kennt es ist quasi wie die heißt
es nochmal das mit wie diese prosieben
event teil bla mit stefan raab wo die
alle mit so risiken aus geht los ich
gerade das ziel ist es dass ich die
anderen dass ich den ball ins andere tor
schießen die spieler jetzt liegen selbst
fast 80 wenn ich über diese dinge hier
fahre ich puste ding und jetzt muss ich
ihn ins tor
machen ja kommt kommt kommt martin 1
alles klar
kollege ich werde dir eigentlich ganz
verboten wenn du die nicht rein machen
würde
egal freunde das spiel geht viereinhalb
minuten noch das können wir auf jeden
fall locker regeln da noch wer klingelt
denn jetzt bei mir man auch bei den
weinheimer ja was ist denn los mit ihm
als ob er den ball gerade nicht rein
gemacht hat ist er den behinderten luca
komm komm komm komm komm mach ihn rein
machen
nein das ist doch gemein wie scheiße ich
bin jeder ach so gute rocket league
spieler wird jetzt denken was sind das
für mit sitzmann nein nein
hahaha ich habe den ball 3d ich übrigens
falls ihr euch fragt wieso ich so ein
bisschen
ich habe irgendwie ein tor gemacht
analysieren wir das noch mal da und
danke kollegen
natürlich fragt wieso das könnte so ein
bisschen behindert abläuft wie waren
gestern abend feiern und ich habe eine
stunde geschlafen oder so bin über den
ball gesprungen und kassiere das 2 1 von
dem ist uns ja gar nicht weil an stellen
wir konzentrieren uns jetzt einfach mal
aufs spiel und versuchen hier direkt mit
diesen ballkontakt das tor zu machen
meine freunde das heißt wir gehen jetzt
mich direkt auf den ball
darauf lassen dem gegner
selbstverständlich gar keine chance denn
wir machen hier direkt das tor nicht
oder eigentlich sagen
ich fahre da denke ich würde gern
gefahren gerade und ich glaube jeder
dummkopf kann dieses spiel besser
spielen aber wir sind auch weg zum tor
wir sind auf dem weg zum tor freunde
freuen und wird das tor sein wird ist
das doch seien wir dass das so sein
nach ihm kam luca nein was ist denn das
für eine messe die sterben wenn keiner
brauche ich mal wieder eindecken eine
minute 48 haben wir doch com luca das
kann doch nicht so schwer sein ich muss
doch einfach nur diesen ball da vorne in
das tor einbrechen comcom kommen das ist
die chance die chance
wir sind vom kosten wir sind vom kasten
jetzt bald alle ganz doll die daumen
drücken
jetzt wird das tor gemacht jetzt wird
sie nicht gemacht so über ihn drüber
jetzt lukas oft singen konzentrieren
jetzt ja nein warum denn den machst du
nicht rein gemacht
hinkommen luca vielleicht kannst dich
wenigstens noch das anschlusstor machen
noch 30 sekunden kommen jetzt springt
hoch an den ball und jetzt hinterher
kommt lukas luca luka das ist doch nicht
so schwer du musst doch einfach nur
rückwärts kommen irgendwie da jetzt ab
aufs tor kommen luca jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt geht
da rein jetzt wieder rein
jetzt geht wer braucht denn gehen wir
einfach nur als ansporn ihn zu zerstören
wir haben auch die möglichkeit dass wir
einen standard spiel spielen uns war es
das dann drei gegen drei das was ist das
denn chaos wir können sogar vier gegen
vier spielen meine karre sieht nicht
schön aus
da hat mir das ganze vorher eigentlich
besser okay die map sieht genauso aus
wie in super mario irgendwie sonne
strecke in assen hat schon längst
angefangen aber klar ich bin gut
ich fand decke alles klar ich gehe ins
match rein und da steht einfach noch
eine minute
ach klar freunde und sie liegen 0 3
hinten
apa klar vorne den ball freunde ich
wohne nicht vorrätig haben
ich habe ihnen alles klar hat den ball
wenn du denkst rocket league ist so
einfach war einfach rückwärts einfach
drückt fährt für das heim
[Musik]
wir haben gerade passiert wo ich warte
einfach durch die letzten zwölf sekunden
freunde vielleicht habe ich die chance
ein tor zu machen vielleicht ein tor zu
machen kommt kommt comcom karre kommt
kommen kommt springen auch nicht so wen
darum was machst du denn da hier wir
sind jetzt wieder in einem chaos jetzt
schon zwar wieder vier gegen vier
anscheinend das ganze match geht genau
jetzt los und er ist dabei kontakt um
über freunde das ist das kann gut werden
dieses match hier liegen händen das
match carlo kacke werden ich mache jetzt
ein tor das wissen nehm ich mir jetzt
einfach mal so vor ort vor thor
vorkommen schreiben schon auch wenn ich
gar nicht will
ich glaube ich sollte einfach meinen
sport verhalten und mit youtube aufhören
sogar der sonst am einschuss meine
schüsse gehen rein in den reihen der
gaudi haben geklärt
ich bin nur auf den ball gucke und ich
bin rückwärts gefahren und schon wieder
und jetzt da dürften und jetzt andere
richtungen und meine kommentar art wie
so schaut dir meine videos ich
kommentiere wie sollen sich hier ist gar
nicht was passiert wenn ich wütend bin
ich mache nämlich jetzt nein wieso hat
denn auf der linie geklärt gefahren
jetzt einfach mal mitten in die mitte
und wer nennt sich mein auto mal endlich
beruhigen würde hier meine chance meine
songs tor zu machen
oh mein gott mach ihn rein marien
reinkommen luca comcom sowieso denn
was ist denn hier los das grab waren
einfach alle autos kurz und da muss doch
jetzt das vor sein
ich habe irgendwie man zerstört freunden
fahren täglich hin aber klar kriegen wir
halt noch das 2 0 1
also aber klar sage ich aber klar zu oft
das sage ich auch in anderen videos
immer so aufgeregt euch das irgendwie
auch ne ja dann ja ich mache jetzt mal
eben vor
[Musik]
leo l wenn ich dich irgendwann kriege
ich will nicht mehr spielen
das macht keinen spaß kann ich nicht mez
verlassen ich bin raus wenn es euch
gefallen hat ich hoffe das klappt zwar
nicht allzu laut zeigt es mir doch mit
einer bewertung und abonniert main kanal
noch mal danke tschüss